what's happening there reject nation
what's going on how is it what's
happening we're gonna watch brooklyn
nine-nine today and this one is called
something or another it doesn't matter
it's in the title if you can't read it
it's on you but what i can ask you to do
is hit that like button it'd be very
much appreciated and also full length
watch laundry single we have screw all
that prepper thanks for editing this
down for us all right let's do it
aunt
aunt aunt aunt aunt god they're
everywhere there are no ants on my desk
because i sanitize it daily what do you
call that
those are your ants they're using a
monitor cable as a land bridge
oh yeah
we have got to fight back this is our
planet just use boyle's cologne it's
repulsive to everything
ah
they bite now sir i think they're just
trying to avoid the cold weather
we should freeze them out
[Laughter]
god i love killing ants
look at these other watching the life
slowly
come out of them
just gotta know how to properly make
them lose breath i wanna see you in the
kitchen
jay did you do something dumb that's a
really good question but actually no i
don't think so it's just been a little
weird lately she's acting kind of
distant have you talked to her no i
don't want to seem desperate
hey
what are you guys doing here oh just
arguing about america did you know that
the sarge doesn't think we should have
given women the right to vote that is
not
but i have a minute right now you want
to go take a walk in the park ah walk in
the park how romantic and i know where
all the murder spots are huh do you want
to see them or avoid them the choice is
yours m'lady terry don't wait go see
those spots
deputy chief wunsch is here to see you
lunch watch i'm a front runner for a job
in the boston pd boston but it's so
close to salem you do know what they do
to witches up there
[Laughter]
the only blemish on my record is our
long history of interpersonal turbulence
the boston commissioner would like to
speak with you about it
i've
come to ask for your help
the commissioner will be great
[Music]
oh i'm sorry i lost my balance you think
i'm bothered by a little spilled
milkshake i'm a food blogger i'm stained
all over okay what is going on with you
two you know how our parents have been
tender sexing each other i hope oh
papa's a gentleman he won't propose
until he gets gina's blessing and she
won't give it to him who says papa are
you little french boy
so my boss hasn't been assigning me any
of the good cases and i found out it's
because i'm dating a cop did he actually
say that no what my colleagues did
you know everybody i work with think of
cops as the enemy or you suck your job
so this is just about your boss
okay yes let's press pause let's pause
the hell out of this let's pause this
like i paused jamie lee curtis in
trading places i haven't seen that movie
but i'm assuming she's naked
paul seems bad jake why aren't you more
upset because sophia's problem isn't
with me it's with her dumb boss that's
something i can fix i'm gonna make him
like me
here is the target jeffrey
i am not going to that please sarge just
come do it for me do it for love damn
jake you know terry loves love i'm it
all right yeah loving terry kelly the
beast
phonier
phonier
ah there it is into the beast
[Laughter]
you
understand
vengeance
yes i do i had a nemesis once carla
bianchi
she wronged me and i crushed her like a
gnat between my fingers
[Laughter]
she came back to school and she made the
next
10 years of my life miserable
it's not worth it be nice to lunch
be nice to watch
you may go now
you just looking for an enabler
i hate this
everyone is looking at us only because
we're equally massive beautiful men in
texas
they look like the men in black
imagine this room is full of super
intelligent robots hell-bent on ending
humanity and you are a working-class
human who just entered the swarm
love this love you keep going well it's
a really weird moment to say you love me
for the first time oh no
oh no
[Laughter]
my friends call me jakey snow pants
cause i'm skiing so much
carving moguls on a black diamond i
prefer cross-country skiing it's not a
sport if gravity does the work for you
yeah gravity sucks
anyway i've been spending most of my
weekends in atlantic city these days
yeah that place is a dump oh now if
you'll excuse me
why would he go someplace he hates so
much unless there was something there he
loves
i bet he loves gambling
just like i'm here in this dump because
of sofia who i now love you're really
going hard on this love thing well i
said it out loud it's on the record i
can't take it back just get on board
terry affairs are being hard
and i won't force you to participate in
our annual themed christmas cards this
year my dad was mary and i was the baby
jesus yeah i know got one live the
nightmare yeah well the list goes on i
signed it amy notarized it i'm a notary
no big deal i'm at the comptroller
this isn't about our lives getting
intertwined okay i'm actually worried
about my mom cause she's been hurt
before this is all moving way too fast
wow
gina you're full of [ __ ] gina the only
reason i didn't tell you guys is because
i don't value you as people so it's like
i know i'm a stage five player just moan
down chicks left and right but my dad's
not like that he would never hurt your
mom
just talk to him you'll see
come on gina bet you five bucks you
can't guess three of the hors d'oeuvres
they're serving
he does like to gamble
chicken satay
tuna tartare
shot glasses of gazpacho
satay
no spatch
oh no
yes
spot
nice to see gazpacho get some love
oh nothing but glass
i'll bet you can't guess how tall the
sarge is
in egg rolls 24.
[Laughter]
you can't remove one glass without
knocking the whole thing over
you didn't say i couldn't grab the top
one
oh don't
[Laughter]
i thought you were leaving were you just
talking to hertzman talking bonding
betting
i should bet him that i can pee for
longer than he can the trick is to pinch
it
i'll be right back nice whoo
got a fast bladder he's a coke addict oh
hello
it's cocaine
[Music]
jake is stupid but he's smart
hey so no big deal but
i arrested your boss and i never should
have coming
and that's cocaine
oh are you sure
five dollars says you're wrong let me
get in there and take a good-looking
smile no don't
what is going on here nothing nothing at
all sophia's cop boyfriend is arresting
me in front of my friends and colleagues
hey everyone
i'm jake so who here saw 12 years a
slave
best picture
was it
[Laughter]
i gave that goblin a good recommendation
your story about the marketer really hit
me
i began to realize that if even you
thought i should take the high road that
was probably the right choice i'm sorry
you didn't get your vengeance mother
holt good one huh but i am still
planning to get some retribution i got
her
a pardon gift
tickets to wicked
she's moving to a second-class city and
i wanted to rub her nose in it enjoy the
understudies madeline
[Laughter]
no
he's a real sweet talker let's cut the
crap okay what are your intentions with
my mother to make love to her every
morning until we die
your mom
is a beautiful brilliant travel agent
she talks to people on the phone who've
seen the whole world i'll never meet
anyone half as good as her she's the
best thing that ever happened to me you
mean other than charles no
fine i give you my blessing but if you
hurt my mom in any way so help me god i
will cut off your son's testicles snap
snap
deal you bagged the babe the boyle boys
are planning a wedding boy boys
i know that you're mad but i talked to
the d.a and he agreed to drop the
charges jeffrey just has to do a little
bit of community service and nothing
will even go on his record not good
enough you have no evidence sofia
there's cocaine on his collar right now
oh not anymore
you're really not reading the vibe right
at all tell you what that's the cocaine
i'm usually very tuned yet
[Laughter]
we're done all right fine i'll talk to
the d.a i'll see if i can cut the
community service in half how's that no
jake not with the case you and i are
done
this shows up bunny
it's heartbreaking i wanted to stop you
grand gesture i took the stairs
a little winded there buddy yeah
romance is hard here will you just talk
for like 20 minutes while i catch my
breath
were romeo and juliet it didn't work for
romeo and juliet that play ends in a
tragic double suicide that's how it ends
why do people like it so much
i was just about to call you i wanted to
thank you for your kind recommendation
and i wanted to give you
this
wicked
starring beth denu
well played raymond
[Laughter]
since i'm not going to boston what i was
only interested in the boston offers
leverage i used it to get a promotion
from the nypd ah
i'm gonna call the commission
i know you never would have recommended
me for that boston post of deep down you
didn't think i deserved the job
you [ __ ]
your confident resolution skills has
made my childhood dreams come true i'm
gonna be a ring bearer you don't think
your dad will make you best man oh i
just assumed he'd ask jake
for starters all the bridesmaids are
gonna be dressed like roseanne from the
television show roseanne oh i like that
show a certified shaman will conduct the
ceremony and the ring bearer will be an
actual wolf oh man i could do it but i
wouldn't be as majestic on all fours
sweating sounds weird i'm into it
you can hold your head up you took the
high road with lunch not entirely
when i was alone in her office i changed
her autocorrect now when she types onch
it gets replaced with
bud
[Laughter]
you like sofia you fought for you should
be proud no you should be changing her
autocorrect what's her last name perez
no it's butt now sophia butt
not really
okay
then let's get soused
let's watch that episode
we won we win we win in the end virtual
win
[Music]
ah yeah
vengeance
vengeance is a dish best served cold
kill bill quoting star trek
just timeless phrases
and it's actually revenge not vengeance
oh no
it's okay it's a good paraphrasing of
the actual quote
yeah
it's good revenge on whoever came up
with it
you can feel it's over now right yeah
it was over a couple lines ago actually
ah yes
doing
the c
in the big n n.y
you gotta love it man
that's a popular before
the mj became legal out there
that was definitely might still be
someone wants them into the
big apple that was the dominant
thing to use
i always differentiated california new
york
was california's about the mj and new
york is about the white powder that's
why we're relaxed lazy stoners that's
right out there they're
angry
energetic
on the go all the time
yeah
so glad we got snl alum
chris cornell yes right
yeah with those velvety pipe secrets oh
my god it's so good to have him in here
hopefully he'll return again sometime
when he gets out of jail for cocaine
or a community service he'll be back
he'll be back man they filmed this in
new york yes where the snl cast is hangs
out that's why they get so much snl
people that's right it probably it's on
the same freaking
network at the time yeah so makes sense
makes a lot of sense that was enjoy that
was really enjoyable having him there
i like like a good gambling back and
forth episode good betting
i like to gamble i don't like to risk
too much though do you like to gamble
forget you got a poker or do you uh are
you a hustler i'm good at poker when
we're playing like
with people
yeah that isn't in like an official
environment like if i'm in a casino i'm
not very good but if i'm like in a back
house playing with like 20 bucks i'm
actually pretty good well about 50
sure yeah i'll play with fifty dollars
you're played two thousand no
yeah
uh
no i i've never bet that much only i
think i've never gotten more than like
fifty dollars yeah i've never really
gone big money anywhere you know and and
then there's i feel like i do better in
personal environments because there's a
bunch of like unwritten rules in casinos
that can easily trip you up if you're
not a pro so i just need to learn the
etiquette
yeah but uh i don't know
i'm gonna miss
miss sophia man i know she was amazing
she was so good one of the most
impressionable guest stars
totally so many deep and rich plotlines
so many moments yeah of memories that
are so coming to mind
they oh
man
they they made love on top of those
creepy dolls i remember that yeah i
remember that graphic scene they threw
in this yeah
this heavily x-rated brooklyn nine-nine
yeah no i mean she was all right
yeah i can live on without her i don't
really get how jake was in love with her
like the last time we saw her he was
clearly still kind of in love with amy
yeah
well and i mean this is one of those
plot lines that at least feels
especially now that it is wrapped like
part part of me was like okay they got
eva longoria so maybe she'll be kind of
a colorful recurring character but i
feel like mostly what she her her role
has just served as kind of a perpetuator
of the tension of the jake and amy you
know story
true so i guess i i maybe would have
liked
a bit more consequence for her character
just because you know it's always fun to
see a guest star like really struck the
comedy and whatever but uh her career is
going to go downhill after this this was
the last dying breath of of her
attempted career's gonna go downhill
that's right how the [ __ ] i mean she had
no trouble she had nothing
i'm not talking about eva longoria i'm
talking about the character oh yeah of
course
what's wrong with that i'm sorry
i'm just trying to to throw you off
she has to get
chris cornell yes
acquitted yes she does
she has to get him completely relieved
of anything even including community
service yeah in order to prove where her
loyalties lie that's true and she's not
a liability to the firm or whatever the
hell it is
so my point being
is yeah that
her career could be taunting jake
peralta could have ruined her career
that's true
i don't blame him or
both of them really
stuff man it's an understandable
scenario it's very relatable and that
holt seeking vengeance ah
that hurt
why
what hurt you know the the the reversal
the switcheroo
why we need hijinks
how boring would it be if they started
getting along
that's true
you know what a comedy comedy needs
problems and tension yes and release
you know i mean i was just yeah you must
hate curb your enthusiasm i
cannot i said this shit's always going
so bad for every day
he brings it upon himself
okay uh
curb's great i cringe a lot during curb
but it's great
oh man if you cringe at everything i can
only imagine you oh yeah
i can't watch too much curb because it's
like a full body cramp it's just like
one big cringe and then it starts to
hurt and get higher to do like um
freaking horror movie contortionist
stuff that's my ultimate goal do that
thing you were doing we were watching
curb your enthusiasm
who comes at night activated on an
impulse don't say his name he comes if
you say his name three times who comes
the cringe man
yeah
i love kerber enthusiasm it's great and
um
yeah i mean that was funny
and then what else is fun oh yes
parents getting it on i like the writing
of this show
because they always manage to make their
a b storylines complement each other
very well yeah
about
all
all the storylines dealt with handling
essentially
someone like above you or superior
whether that be handling parents
handling boss
or handling colleague up for promotion
you know so i think the way they manage
to intertwine all three stories they're
really good at thematically lining them
all up where it's just like enough
thematically
or doesn't feel like the stories are
overshadowing one another but
i really do uh i keep feeling we're
gonna get more time with holds dad not
hold oh boils down boyle
thank you his name is chris parnell
johnson not cornell what's your deal
my bad dude i'm just trying to make you
look bad it's okay it happens man uh so
yeah you have
um
yeah the dad and he was only here for
like a brief amount of time like every
time yeah
yeah he literally i imagined he showed
up to shoot each day for like an hour
and then they were like you're good
character actors more than that
a full day but only a wonderful day
uh i mean usually they book them for a
full day and then they shoot for an hour
yeah it's a boring ass process
it's never as fun being on set as it
looks no unless you're like actually
working there yeah unless you've got
like a very time consuming and all
hands-on task but if you've ever been
just like i'm here my friends working on
this oh god that [ __ ] is so
so remarkably boring
gotta be real quiet and not go too many
places don't do anything to not disrupt
the shoot can't talk to the crew really
because they're trying to work because
they're working way more than the cast
is and yet the crew is getting paid
significantly less than the cast
because you gotta keep the cast
comfortable
for their few minutes to film
and then you start talking about this on
set and then there's some how mutiny
that's the fun part about visiting
especially network show sets
because you see just like the actors are
pretty much chilling all day
and then they work for a couple hours
um because they got to be relaxed to be
on camera that's right yeah where the
crew is just like
all
day gotta make this as efficient and
compact as possible and it's not gonna
go that way but we gotta try
but all of them are replaceable that's
right
except the actors
anyone can hang a light
yeah
yeah yeah i'm all right guys brooklyn
nine-nine well
what'd you guys think of john's reaction
to deliver to everything you wanted it
to be please leave your thoughts down
below
for next time be very honest with john
you know he needs to improve how he
reacts to things so
please he's taking advice
from all you people you without facing
your thumbnails just
go tell him tell tell him tell him away
oh he he takes it all in yep i read it
all
right
i'm sorry are you trying to end the
video i was trying to say hey
deonte w tongue punch fart box now we
could easily do another shout out riffin
on your hilarious
username here but i wanted to look up
what the name deonte means do you know
what it means deontay do you have any
idea what it means you know how you are
have you ever traveled
to the internet to see what your name
means have you ever learned what an
outstanding
name
you have
just how great of a outstanding
personality
that you have how it informs your
personality this name of yours that you
are a traveler who has an outstanding
personality
that's what your name means dude and
it's a french african origin dude
perfect you could travel to france and
then africa and then looking at your
thumbnail on patreon
definitely french i would say right man
hey speak some of the language of love
to us
and our hearts will melt partly because
not not your looks or anything but your
outstanding personality
that's what will get the key to our
affection going
and then we can all get into a pile
together
and uh
[Music]
you know like read a book or something
sorry haven't you started talking
baguette you should share some wine have
a deontay personality i don't i don't i
have not well traveled and my
personality is quite bland
but it's okay i'm inspired by deontay
every single day
and uh and that's your shout outs your
shout out happy new year don't worry the
rest of the year we will do nothing but
time punches
[Music]
you